very happy to be interviewing caitlyn
bristow for dancing with the stars how
does it feel babe
i honestly just keep like oh wrong way i
keep moving to the side of being like
i've arrived it's finally happening this
is
years in the making i know that you knew
about this
kind of long before the other
competition did maybe you've been
planning it for years
do you feel you've got a little bit of
an advantage i know you were working out
hard and really prepping
i know people keep saying like does
katelyn have an advantage from knowing
and from dancing
and all these things and i actually feel
like i have a disadvantage in a way
because i am unlearning everything i
thought i knew about dance
and uh it's been way more challenging
than i thought
oh that's interesting because you you
mentally have wanted to do this for so
long
what has it felt like to be in those
rehearsals have you been surprised by
your emotional reactions to this process
during like any kind of rehearsal it's
so funny because i think i have a smile
on my face the whole time and then i
start dancing i'm very serious
um but the whole like i go home
sometimes and i get emotional just
because
it's truly truly truly a dream i think
everyone knows this is a dream for me
so tell me how those rehearsals are
going what can you tell me about the
first dance
well i can tell you that it's
challenging and uh
but that there's a lot going on and i
thought my hips could move the way i
wanted them to
but it turns out they can't
you're somebody who's so hard on
yourself and i know you posted the other
day
kind of having a moment saying those
trolls finally got to you
what was that like for you did you think
that they could even get you to that
place
anymore were you surprised that you were
affected
yeah i was a little surprised because i
had to like do a little one
two like wake up caitlyn uh because it's
like it was so silly but i think i was
just so
mentally drained and i was tired and i
was
hormonal and it was just like anything
was going to set me off
and so i took my moment i cried for like
an hour i felt all my feelings and i
don't like to stay there long and i just
bounce back and remember that i'm living
my dream
right now and that uh nothing should get
to me like that
well it's hard because look you're
somebody who
knows what it's like to be in the
spotlight for a whole tv season of a
show
but you haven't done that in a while so
are you preparing yourself for
look i'm gonna be on tv every week again
now and i'm gonna have to face this
criticism every week and if so how will
you rally against it
i think i'm just gonna choose if when
it's that time of the month i'm just
gonna stay off social media
but yeah i think you know being so
removed from being on a show for so long
you kind of forget how
nasty people can be but you just have to
ignore the ones that are you know
trying to get you down because there's
so many nice people that are trying to
build you up
so i'm gonna focus on that and uh it's
it's been a while but i mean i've i've
prepared for this so
not only have i been working out in
boxing but i've also been going to
therapy and like working on myself so
i think i'm gonna be okay what is your
personal mantra in all this
and how will you win dancing with the
stars my gosh
bruce i should have thought of one um i
feel like it's all
what did your therapist tell you no
there's my mom she says things like
dance with your heart and your feet will
follow um which is always a good one but
i think it's about like
i think it's 20 20 you gotta roll with
the punches i think that's what this is
all about it's
it's going to be fun it's going to be
challenging it's going to be a roller
coaster and
sometimes you're going to let people
down sometimes you're going to make
people happy just have to roll with all
the punches and
and just enjoy the process everyone
that's done this show who has talked to
me says
it goes by so fast it's such a unique
experience
there's ups and downs but like be
present and enjoy every moment so that's
what i'm gonna try and do
have you talked to hannah brown she's a
fellow bachelorette she just won
i mean you were originally supposed to
be on the show first but what did hannah
tell you about winning
yeah i'm glad i've had other people who
have gone on before me now they give me
all the advice
um last night i used the foot bath that
she gave me it's like an ice bath
and i just like loaded that thing up
with ice i was like oh this is gonna
feel so good
i don't know if you've ever tried an ice
bath it was the worst thing i've ever
done
um but so she gave me the ice bath she
said same thing as everything everyone
else it's
enjoy it it goes by so fast so even
every blister on my foot i i like look
at with love right now i'm like
hey you you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing
um who do you think your toughest
competition is
and is it carol baskin it is well sure
is it i don't know i don't know what
america wants so
i'm gonna go with aj from the baxter
boys because
i've been to his concerts so i've seen
him dance and then and he's very lovable
and then i'm gonna go with johnny weir
because he's got such a great
personality
and clearly insane moves my last
question for you mentioned people
building you up
how much is jason your rock in all this
what did he say to you when those trolls
came for you
he just jason's the kind of guy that
like nothing really everything kind of
bounces off him so he doesn't understand
like
feeling your feelings so he's looking at
me like what are you nuts like
you're literally on dancing with the
stars and you're like
you've worked so hard and you've got all
this stuff going on and
it was so nice because i was like
reality check i like that i like that
i'm so excited for you i think you're
coming for carol i think you got this
i'm coming for carol don't tell her
you